so und wir sind zurück hier in den
Haushaltsberatungen im Deutschen
Bundestag mittlerweile beim Einzelplan
25 wohnen Stadtentwicklungen Bauwesen
angekommen ein Etat von 7,33 Milliarden
Euro hat die Bundesministerin Clara
Gallwitz damit eine Verdopplung des
Vorjahres das liegt vor allen Dingen an
der
wohngeldreform und Markus Bühl
hatte eben das Wort jetzt gibt es aber
momentan gerade eine kurz in dervention
und eine Erwiderung
und zwar am Anfang des Jahres im Januar
und nicht erst am Ende des Jahres so wie
es wahrscheinlich sein wird wir erklären
sich das dass sie das völlig ignoriert
haben das ist unverständlich dass sie
das nicht aufgegriffen haben der
Lutscher von der Union hat jetzt hier
noch ganz kurz das Wort gehabt und der
da hat der war nämlich der letzte Redner
der SPD kann darauf noch erwidern
dass sie es nicht wahrgenommen haben
heißt ja nicht dass wir nicht reagiert
haben
das ist nicht dasselbe wir haben die
Bewilligungszeiträume beispielsweise auf
24 Monate verlängert seine eminent
wichtige Vereinfachung seine eminent
wichtige Vereinbarung wir haben an
verschiedenen Stellen versuchte weitere
Vereinfachungen zu machen die wir auch
vom Bundesrat sozusagen diskutiert haben
aber ich will an dieser Stelle auch eins
sagen ich habe es ja gesagt wir wissen
um die Belastung der Kommunen wir wissen
darum aber im Abwägungsprozess sage ich
ihnen ist für uns die Hilfe für die
betroffenen Menschen das wichtigste und
ich habe mich sehr sehr vielen
Betroffenen ja ich habe mir sehr sehr
vielen Betroffenen gesprochen
Amtsleitern Sachbearbeitern und
Dezernenten die sich dieser Aufgabe
tatsächlich auch stellen und ich möchte
gerne dass sie sozusagen nicht einfach
den nicht einfach nicht einfach die
Gelegenheit nutzen auf den Bund zu
zeigen sondern so wie sie es in den
Jahren zuvor in jeder Sitzung gemacht
haben auch daran zu appellieren dass die
Länder ihre Kommunen mit dem
entsprechenden Personal und mit der
entsprechenden Grundfinanzierung
ausstatten das wäre sehr gut ich kann
das ihnen in Nordrhein-Westfalen in
wenigen Sätzen sozusagen detailliert
erläutern das können wir nach der
Sitzung machen vielen Dank ich habe gar
nicht mitgekriegt dass sie die
Zwischenfrage gestellt haben ich hatte
eine ganz andere idee
tja sonst hätte vielleicht die
Zwischenfrage zugelassen aber jetzt geht
es jetzt hier weiter in der Debatte um
den Einzelplan 25 wohnen
Stadtentwicklung und Bauwesen und ich
nehme an und hör mal zu jawohl das
nämlich der von mir schon aufgerufen im
Markus Bühl jetzt für die AFD das Wort
bekommt er ist Mitglied im
haushaltsanschluss
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren
bezahlbares Wohnen war eines der
Hauptthemen im Wahlkampf 2021 von den
Parteien die heute die Vertreter der
Bundesregierung Stellen etwas über ein
Jahr danach ist Bauen und Wohnen so
teuer wie nie die Inflation ist dabei
maßgeblicher Treiber allen voran die
energieverteuerung die Regierung Merkel
und sie die Links grüne Bundesregierung
sind maßgeblich verantwortlich für diese
horrenden Energiekosten
von der co2-bepreisung bis zur geplanten
Abschaltung der letzten Kernkraftwerke
nächstes Jahr sie zeigen ganz klar was
ihnen selbst in Zeiten größter Not
wichtiger ist
gleichzeitig nehmen Sie Abermilliarden
Schulden auf um Hilfspakete zu schnüren
die erst durch ihre Politik nötig
geworden sind was wir brauchen ist eine
fähige Bundesregierung die endlich die
Probleme an der wurzelpackt deiner
übrigen sich auch die von uns selbst zu
zahlenden Hilfspakete
für viele Haushalte in Deutschland ist
wohnen nahezu unbezahlbar geworden
jährlich 400.000 Wohnungen hat diese
Bundesregierung vollmundig am Anfang
ihrer Amtszeit versprochen dieses Jahr
werden es weit unter 300.000 fertig
gestellte Wohnungen sein verfehlte
Ergebnisse sind typisch für ihre
linksgrüne Politik
für einen Wohnungsprojekt hat links gelb
jedoch gegen unsere Anträge und stimmen
die Weichen gestellt der Bundeskanzler
bekommt eine neue 250 Quadratmeter große
Dienstwohnungen in Berlin Mitte es ist
überhaupt nicht zu verstehen warum mit
diesen schwierigen Zeiten mit steigender
Inflation und Energiekrise die Regierung
an einem Erweiterungsbau des
Bundeskanzleramtes festhält der Bau soll
der Bau soll nach jetzigen Stand 777
Millionen Euro kosten und damit hunderte
Millionen Euro mehr als noch im Frühjahr
diesen Jahres bis zur Kostensteigerung
auf eine Milliarde ist es nun nicht mehr
weit zum Vergleich ein süddeutscher
Autohersteller hat vor zwei Jahren eine
hochmoderne digitalisierte Fabrik im
Umfang von 30 Fußballfeldern für ca
730 Millionen Euro in Betrieb genommen
die Bundesregierung hingegen können sich
ein völlig überdimensioniertes Bauwerk
während sie gleichzeitig den Bürgern
Spartipps beim Heizen gibt stoppen Sie
diesen Erweiterungsbau des
Bundeskanzleramtes wir werden im
Haushalt in dieser Form natürlich nicht
zustimmen ich danke für die
Aufmerksamkeit
nächster Redner in dieser Debatte ist
Markus Kurt für Bündnis 90 die Grünen
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin verehrte Kolleginnen
und Kollegen meine Damen und Herren
dieser Haushalt bietet sowohl kurz-
[Musik]
und ja natürlich ist das eine
Herausforderung verwaltungstechnisch wir
haben aber zum Beispiel mit der
Möglichkeit von
abschlagsvorschusszahlungen zum Beispiel
Instrumente geschaffen die man die
Auszahlung vereinfachen kann und es ist
jetzt auch Vorbereiter sind auch
Vorbereitungsmöglichkeiten jetzt für die
Kommunen und es bleiben an der eine oder
anderen Stelle wo Kommunen besonders
unter ausgestattet sind natürlich
vielleicht noch hier und dort
Schwierigkeiten aber Herr Uhl soll denn
dann die Konsequenz aus dem ganzen sein
dass man gar nichts macht Herr Uhl ihre
Rede war eine Empfehlung für
ambitionslosigkeit das kann doch nicht
die Antwort in dieser Lage sein
sondern man muss dies versuchen es ist
auch ja so dass die Jobcenter ein halbes
Jahr lang auch nicht durch den
vorrangigen Anspruch des wohngelds
prüfen das ist auch ein bisschen holprig
das gebe ich offen zu diese
übergangsmöglichkeit aber die
Alternative wäre auf diesen qualitativ
großen Schritt in diesen
Herausforderungen herausfordernden
Zeiten zu verzichten und das geht
definitiv nicht da haben wir uns
eindeutig als Ampel anders entschieden
und natürlich sind wir auch bei den kurz
bis auch mittelfristigen Elementen
weiterhin dabei sie sind Schwerpunkte in
diesem Haushalt geblieben das ist der
soziale Wohnungsbau aber wir blicken
auch weiter in die Zukunft mit zum
Beispiel dem maßgabebeschluss den wir
als Haushälter zum Thema neue
wohngemeinnützigkeit getroffen haben
wollen wir die Voraussetzung dafür
schaffen wollen wir die Voraussetzungen
dafür schaffen dass nicht nur mit Hilfe
des Wohngeldes Mietzahlungen
subventioniert werden denn das ist ja
letztlich was dort passiert sondern das
im Bestand gewirtschaftet werden kann
mit dem Ziel langfristig qualitativ
hochwertigen Wohnraum bezahlbar zu
halten für die Menschen das sind
qualitatives politikziel des nachhaltig
ist und das werden wir jetzt endlich auf
den Weg bringen
und gleich ist gilt beim Bereich
Forschung wo wir noch ebenfalls in einem
maßgabebeschluss deutlich gemacht haben
dass wir in der Entwicklung neuer
Baustoffe holzbaustrategie das werden
wir noch qualifizieren gegenüber dem
Ministerium dass wir dort eine
Weiterentwicklung brauchen wir brauchen
allerdings auch nicht nur Forschung
sondern wir müssen die jetzt schon
vorhandenen Möglichkeiten
serielle Sanierung Einsatz neuer
Baustoffe jetzt auch in der Breite in
die Anwendung bringen die Möglichkeiten
sind da und das ist auch in Zeiten von
Schwierigkeiten das Carbon gestützte
Baustoffe Zement immer teurer werden
dringend notwendig mit Blick auf die
Baukosten
zum Thema altersgerecht wohnen wo sich
alle drei Berichterstatter im
Haushaltsausschuss einig waren muss ich
gar nicht viel sagen da ist klar dass
wir angesichts der alternden
Gesellschaft hier aufstocken mussten
eigentlich das konnten wir gar nicht
anders machen ich glaube wir hätten
sogar Thorsten Herbst da noch noch mehr
gewollt wir freuen uns nämlich auch dass
dieses Programm sich eines
regenmittelabflusses erfreut und dass da
sehr schnell sehr viel abfließen kann
und
dann will ich noch eingehen zum Schluss
auf das Thema lebenswerte Städte ich
glaube man kann nicht über diesen
Haushalt reden ohne über auch das
Programm der Sanierung kommunaler
Einrichtungen im Bereich Sport Jugend
und Kultur zu reden wir stehen hier
jetzt vor der Phase der Entscheidung der
aktuellen projektscheibe und ich glaube
das ist auch ein wesentlicher Anteil bei
der Unterstützung unserer Kommunen so
etwas Wichtiges wie ihre Sportstätten
die vielfältig aus den 60er 70er-Jahren
des vergangenen Jahrhunderts jetzt doch
reparaturbedürftig sind ihnen dabei
unter die Arme zu greifen
und da möchte ich auch noch mal an
dieser Stelle dann den Bundesrat und der
dann doch häufig vorgetragenen Kritik
durch die Länder auch mal entgegenhalten
und Sie bitten sich diesen Haushalt
insgesamt mehr anzusehen denn viele
[Musik]
Investitionsmaßnahmen oder Unterstützung
von Investitionen die wir machen die
kommen direkt in Kommunen und der
Landesebene zugut und ich glaube das
sollte man auch mit anerkennen wenn man
an anderer Stelle Kritik gegenüber dem
und äußert und da würde ich mich freuen
einfach wenn diese Anerkennung auch dem
Deutschen Bundestag entgegengebracht
werden würden
und ebenso mit Blick auf die Länder
will ich noch ganz kurz das Thema
Mittelabfluss ansprechen das muss man
als
haushaltsverantwortlicher tun an der
Stelle und wir haben dort mit mehreren
Maßgabe Beschlüssen auch und das
angesehen und wollen dort mehr Nachdruck
sozusagen hinbringen das mit das Geld
was wir auch Kommunen beispielsweise zur
Verfügung stellen dann auch schließlich
vernünftig im Sinne einer nachhaltigen
lebenswärtigen Zukunft im Städtebau
eingesetzt werden kann vielen Dank
Markus Korte war das für Bündnis 90 die
Grünen im Bundestag Karin Ley wird nun
für die Linksfraktion sprechen sie hat
sich schon im Vorfeld besonders über die
neue Festlegung der mietenstufen
beschwert diese kritisiert wir werden
jetzt eventuell weitere Details dazu
hören meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren ist bräuchte eigentlich
Seite mit geringem und mittlerem
Einkommen
doch leider haben wir gerade mal eine
Millionen Sozialwohnungen das ist ein
historischer Tiefstand und nicht zu
akzeptieren
wir brauchen also eigentlich fünf
Millionen Sozialwohnungen mehr die
Schaffung von Sozialwohnungen muss jetzt
die oberste Priorität aller Neubau
Tätigkeit haben denn mit mehr teuren
Wohnungen ist diesen Menschen nicht
geholfen
doch die Ziele der Bundesregierung
100.000 neue Sozialwohnungen im Jahr zu
schaffen werden grandios verfehlt im
letzten Jahr wurden gerade mal 23.000
neue Sozialwohnungen gebaut und die
Zahlen sind rückläufig wenn wir hier
nicht vorankommen dann erreichen wir die
versprochenen 100.000 Sozialwohnungen
nicht im Jahr sondern bestenfalls in der
Legislatur und das ist nicht akzeptabel
schlimmer noch jedes Jahr fallen mehr
Sozialwohnungen aus der Bindung wie neue
gebaut werden im letzten Jahr gab es
unterm Strich ein Minus von 27.000
Sozialwohnungen weniger wenn das so
weitergeht dann ist der soziale
Wohnungsbau bald Geschichte und das darf
nicht passieren
nun kann man natürlich sagen das ist
alles noch von der alten Regierung
geerbt doch die weichen die sie stellen
reichen eben bei weitem nicht aus mit
einer Verdoppelung oder einer
Verdreifachung der Mittel kann man keine
Vervierfachung des Neubaus erzählen das
ist doch völlig klar und
1,275 Milliarden Euro fragt Dich
ausgegeben im Jahr das ist für die
gesamte Bundesrepublik für den Neubau
von Wohnungen eine lächerlich geringe
Summe
und zweitens muss es darum gehen dieses
permanente Auslaufen der Bindungen
endlich zu verhindern dieses irrsinnige
Prinzip das muss einfach gestoppt werden
es ist doch nicht nachhaltig eine
Sozialwohnung zu finanzieren und nach 15
Jahren fällt sie aus der
preis-bindung und das erreichen wir eben
am besten durch eine neue
wohnungsgemeinnützigkeit der nur diese
garantiert einmal Sozialwohnung immer
Sozialwohnungen ja wir sind uns da einig
aber weit und breit von diesem Gesetz
keine Spur
ich habe immer gesagt man muss das zu
Beginn der Legislatur machen damit es
eben kein Nischenprodukt bleibt sondern
dass wir jetzt noch in den Wiederaufbau
eines großen gemeinnützigen
wohnungssektors investieren können den
wir in Deutschland noch einmal hatten
aber stattdessen geben wir weiter
fordermittel für private
börsennotierte wohnungskonzerne aus das
ist doch völlig absurd
wir als LINKE wollen die neue
wohnungsgemeinnützigkeit schnell
einführen und wir wollen dort viel Geld
investieren 18 Milliarden schlagen wir
dazu vor im Jahr und sagen Sie bitte
nicht dass dafür kein Geld da ist also
dieses Sondervermögen für Aufrüstung
dass sie hier in Windeseile
durchgewunken haben das wäre im
gemeinnützigen Wohnungsbau deutlich
besser angelegtes Geld gewesen
und es muss auch nicht immer Neubau sein
wir wollen auch in Ankauf von Wohnungen
und in den Umbau des Bestandes
investieren
Parkhäuser zur Genossenschaften
leerstehende Bürogebäude zu
Sozialwohnungen das ist unser Programm
man kann auch die Kommunen darin
unterstützen die massenhaft
privatisierten Wohnungen zurückzukaufen
es wäre das mindeste hier in einen
rekommunalisierungsfonds zu investieren
und dafür bräuchten wir natürlich auch
ein verbessertes Vorkaufsrecht aber
selbst ein Jahr nachdem das Gericht das
bestehende Vorkaufsrecht gekämpft hat
weit und breit keine Spur von einem
neuen Gesetz die Kommunen stehen den
Spekulanten jetzt mit leeren Händen
gegenüber ich finde das total
vielen steht zum Thema Mietrecht der
sowieso nicht im Koalitionsvertrag aber
selbst das lässt auf sich warten gerade
jetzt vor diesem Winter wäre ein
bietenstopp und ein besserer
Kündigungsschutz höchste Zeit
das Chaos vom Wohngeld schließlich wäre
vermeidbar gewesen wenn man unseren
Vorschlag angenommen hätte nämlich die
alten Anträge die bereits bewilligt
waren pauschal und vorläufig vor ein
Jahr zu verlängern damit die Kolleginnen
und Kollegen die jetzt Überstunden
machen müssen und am Wochenende arbeiten
müssen diese Anträge erstmal die neuen
Anträge hätten bearbeiten können das
wäre richtig gut gewesen
Klimaschutz meine Damen und Herren muss
ohne Mieterhöhung möglich sein deswegen
fordern wir 5 Milliarden Euro um erstmal
bei den energieintensiven
Nachkriegsbauten anzufangen und zu
klimagerechten Städten gehört eben auch
eine gut ausgestattete
städtebauforderung lassen sie uns mehr
Geld in die Begrünung von Dächern und
Fassaden in essbare Gärten und in die
Aufforstung der Städte investieren
klimagerechte Städte sind lebenswerte
Städte
kommen Sie bitte zum Schluss Frau
Kollegin guter Letzt zu Klima zu
lebenswerten Städten gehört eben auch
Musik gehören Konzerte und gehören
Club ein Schallschutzprogramm gefordert
auch davon leider keine Spur das
Clubsterben muss verhindert werden dass
Monopoly und das Monopoly müssen beendet
werden vielen Dank
soweit Karin Ley die Sprecherin für
Mieten war und Wohnungspolitik hier der
Linksfraktion ist zum Schluss noch mal
auf die Nacht Szene eingegangen auch da
guckt man natürlich mit Sorge auf den
kommenden Winter oder der schon da ist
Thorsten Herbst spricht nur für die
FDP-Fraktion
kein Haushaltsentwurf geht unverändert
durch das Parlament das gilt auch für
den Etat des baumministeriums und ich
bin froh dass es gelungen ist gemeinsam
mit den Partnern in der Ampel diesen
etwa noch deutlich besser zu machen
und es gab nicht nur einen
aufwuchsfinanziell der natürlich ein
hohem Maße durch das Wohngeld verursacht
wurde sondern wir haben weiterhin eine
höchst investitionsanteile aller
Einzelhaushalte hier im Bundestag ich
bin stolz dass wir zu diesem
rekordinvestitionsvolumen von 71 mehrten
Euro in diesem Bundeshaushalt beitragen
worum geht es uns mit diesem Haushalt
der erste Punkt ist wir wollen privates
Wohneigentum ermöglichen Wohneigentum
meine Damen und Herren ist der Schlüssel
zu einer stabilen Gesellschaft und es
ist auch der Schlüssel zur Schaffung von
ausreichend Wohneigentum und dem führen
wir uns verpflichtet
und anders als die Linksfraktion immer
behauptet sind auch die Masse der
Vermieter nicht Großkonzerne zwei
Drittel fast zwei Drittel aller
Wohnungen in Deutschland werden durch
private Kleinvermieter zur Verfügung
gestellt die haben ein zwei Wohnungen
und ohne die an anderer Schmarrn ohne
die an Investitionen Sie es richtig
düster am Wohnungsmarkt aus
und deshalb ist das auch richtig dass
wir gesagt haben wir beenden das wenig
zielgerichte Baukindergeld und wir
starten ein neues Neubau Förderprogramm
damit mehr privat Wohnungseigentum
schaffen werden kann
und es ist auch richtig dass wir mehr
Mittel für das altersgerechte umbauen
mobilisiert haben der Kollege kurt hat
das schon angesprochen denn wer länger
in den eigenen vier Wänden wohnen kann
das ist nicht nur eine
wohnungspolitische Dimension das hat
auch eine gesellschaftspolitische und
sozialpolitische Dimension und wir
wollen dass Menschen in den eigenen vier
Wänden in Würde älter werden können
der zweite Punkt und ich glaube der ist
jenseits des Geldes eine große
Herausforderung ja wir müssen bauen
bezahlbarer und schneller machen und
gerade jetzt wo wir alle merken dass der
Kostendruck zunimmt das heißt wir müssen
noch mal uns Standards anschauen
gesetzliche Vorschriften Genehmigung und
auch den Weg frei machen das neue
bautechnologien schneller zur Anwendung
kommen ich setze da auch auf die
Ergebnisse des Bundes bezahlbare
Wohnraum und ich glaube zusammen mit dem
baumministerium werden wir auch
Fortschritte erreichen da bin ich mir
sicher
wir wollen auch dafür sorgen dass wir
insgesamt beim Bauen mehr Innovationen
erreichen das Tempo ist dort zu langsam
und wenn ich nur einige Stichworte nenne
Carbon Beton sehr jelles bauen Holzbau
neue Dämmstoffe wir müssen schneller zur
praktischen Anwendung zu kommen um
a-material zu sparen auch CO2-Emissionen
bei Bau und im Betrieb zu senken das ist
nicht nur eine ökologische
Herausforderung sondern auch eine
ökonomische Notwendigkeit wenn wir
weniger Energie verbrauchen macht sich
das auch im Geldbeutel bemerkbar und
deshalb bin ich froh dass wir mehr
Mittel für die baufrischung mobilisiert
haben
wenn wir uns im Land umschauen und zu
Hause in unseren Wahlkreisen das sehen
wir dass wir viele öffentliche Gebäude
haben die sehr energieintensiv sind das
sind Schwimmhallen Sportstätten auch
denkmalgeschützte Museen wo man oft die
Umgebung mitteilt und deshalb ist es so
wichtig dass wir auch da herangehen den
Energieverbrauch bei öffentlichen
Gebäuden zu senken und deshalb haben wir
eine neue Förderrunde zur Sanierung
kommunaler Einrichtung Sportstätten
erreicht da auch ein herzliches
Dankeschön an Koalitionspartner
und wir nehmen auch zur Kenntnis meine
Damen und Herren dass wir nicht nur
Wohnungsbaupolitik aus dem Blickwinkel
der Ballungsräume machen denn es gibt
nicht nur den Prenzlauer Berg es gibt
auch die Region und Prenzlau die
Uckermark und dort sind die
Herausforderung ganz anders denn auf der
einen Seite sehen wir wohnungsnoten auf
der anderen Seite Wohnungs Leerstand
deshalb ist es für uns ganz ganz wichtig
dass wir auch die Lebensqualität in
ländlichen Region erhalten und es werden
Mobilität bezahlbar machen um nicht noch
mehr Druck auf die Metropolen zu
erzeugen
und zum Abschluss noch ein Wort zur
Union das ist ja schon sehr interessant
wenn man die ersten reden heute hört
dann kritisieren die Haushaltspolitiker
Union dass wir viel zu viel Geld
ausgeben wenn wir die Reden der
Fachpolitiker der Union hören wird immer
kritisiert dass wir zu wenig Geld
ausgeben das heißt sie fordern mehr
Ausgaben ohne zu sagen wie diese
Ausgaben gedeckt werden dass ein
Widerspruch den sollten Sie mal intern
versuchen zu erklären
und im Gegensatz zu ihnen kann ich sagen
bei uns als ampelkondition ist der Etat
des baumministeriums in hervorragende
Händen und wir haben Geld mit dem wir
arbeiten können wir können bauen
beschleunigen wohnbezahlbar halten
privates Wohneigentum fördern das ist
der Unterschied zur Union meine Damen
und Herren
Thorsten Herbst hat hier noch mal auf
die Unterschiede der Fraktionen
hingewiesen wobei wir die ja auch gerade
in der Bau- und Wohnungspolitik auch in
der Debatte mitkriegen und genau
erläutern kann das jetzt Michael
Breilmann für die Unionsfraktion
Kollegen wenn ich jetzt hier so die
Lobeshymnen höre der Koalitionäre zu den
Hilfen in dieser Energiekrise dann kann
ich dem relativ einfach entgegnen und
das ist nicht mein Urteil sondern das
ist der Urteil von der
Wohnungswirtschaft und auch der
kommunalen Familie es ist viel zu spät
und es ist alles viel zu kompliziert
und wir haben zu der letzten Debatte
auch schon angesprochen die Schonzeit
für diese Regierung die ist längst
vorbei dieser Etat 2023 der kann sich
nicht mehr hinter Zuständigkeiten der
Vorgängerregierung verstecken und es ist
gerade schon deutlich geworden ja der
Baubereich der steckt in einer tiefen
Krise und da finde ich es nicht gut wenn
in der Öffentlichkeit von Frau
Ministerin galwitz Nachholbedarf
eingeräumt wird aber die Situation
Vorgängerregierung versucht wird in die
Schuhe zu schieben ich kann den wirklich
nur entgegnen wenn die unionsgeführten
Bundesregierung in den letzten Jahren
nicht so wirtschaftlich gut geh
haushaltet hätten dann könnten Sie hier
Ihre teuren Versprechung und ihre
schaufensterpolitik sich gar nicht
leisten so sieht's aus
und sie liefen liefern mit ihrer Politik
auch keine wirksamen Antworten zur
Lösung der schwerwiegenden Problem
e wenn ich das hier alles so höre und
sehe dann handeln sie eher nach dem
Motto wir schaffen zwar keine 300 bis
400.000 neue Wohnungen jährlich sind
aber in der Lage mit unserer Politik
jedes Jahr mindestens drei bis 400.000
Menschen in diesem Land zu verunsichern
mit großem rum haben sie kürzlich ein
Bündnis bezahlbarer Wohnraum im
Kanzleramt zelebriert und ein Katalog
mit 187 Einzelmaßnahmen gegen
Deutschlands Wohnungskrise vorgelegt das
ist aber alles auf Basis eines
minimalkonsensors vieler Gruppen erfolgt
und wir finden eigentlich kaum neue
handlungs
und wir haben sowieso kein Erkenntnis
sondern wir haben ein Umsetzungsproblem
nicht nur bis zur formalen Genehmigung
eines Bauantrages vergeht immer mehr
Zeit es dauert auch immer länger bis ein
genehmigtes Projekt fertig wird gut
sechs Wochen vor dem Beginn des neuen
Jahres braucht es dringend Klarheit über
neue förderkulisten und Konsequenz muss
auch sein die geplanten Bauvorschriften
und alles was dem Bau 2023 verteuert
einem klaren Realitätscheck zu
unterziehen das Dickicht der
Bauvorschriften es muss dringend
gelichtet werden
und ich frage mich auch ich frage mich
auch welchen Stellenwert haben
eigentlich die Kommunen bei dieser
Koalition es ist ja gerade schon
deutlich geworden bei der SPD wir
schaffen zusätzliche Arbeitsaufgaben wir
schaffen zusätzlichen Arbeitsanfall und
für neue Stellen sollen dann Kommunen
und Länder besorgen das ist eine
Arbeitsaufteilung die können wir nicht
akzeptiert
und so finden sich in diesem Metall im
Vergleich zum letzten Haushalt viele
viele kommunalrelevante Minderausgaben
wie zum Beispiel auch im Bereich
altersgerecht Umbau
und wenn ich dann höre dass die
Koalition da mehr hätte machen wollen
insbesondere von der grünen Seite da
kann ich mich nur wundern warum sie dann
unserem Antrag im Haushaltsausschuss zu
neuen zusätzlichen Mitteln nicht
zugestimmt haben das hätten Sie tun
können wir haben diesen Antrag
eingereicht
und gut gemeint ist halt nicht immer gut
gemacht wie man beim Wohngeld sieht die
Zahl der Wohngeld Haushalte soll durch
eine Reform aufgrund 2 Millionen mehr
als verdreifacht werden und da droht
Nummern eine Überbelastung der
wohngeldämter in den Kommunen ich kann
das auch für meinen Kreis nur bestätigen
in Recklinghausen die Einführung zum
Januar 2023 sie ist nicht umsetzbar und
es droht hier wirklich der Kollaps des
wohngeldsystems
und das sage nicht ich und da sollten
Sie zuhören da sollten Sie vielleicht
darauf hören dass sagt auch der Deutsche
Städtetag ihr gesetzeshandwerk sich
schlecht gemacht und kommt viel zu spät
und die Bearbeitung der Anträge dauert
ja jetzt schon bis zu sechs Monate vor
kurzem kamen dann nun endlich auch das
Konzept zur wohnungseigentumsförderung
aus dem Bauministerium von den eigenen
Koalitionären im Mai eingefordert für
September zum September hatten wir aber
auch noch nichts allerdings hatte der
Beschluss auch der Koalitionäre die
klare Vorgabe an die Regierung
formuliert das Schwellenhaushalte
langfristig auch mit tilgungszuschüssen
unterstützt werden das sieht das Konzept
jetzt nicht vor und spätestens jetzt
spätestens in diesen Tagen dürfte klar
sein dass diese ampelregierung ein
Problem mit Eigentumsförderung aber mit
auch mit Eigentums Erhalt in Bezug auf
private Immobilien hat
anstatt endlich bei der Erbschaftssteuer
die Freibeträge anzupassen um sich nicht
an der steigenden Inflation zu
bereichern verschärfen sie die Situation
weitgehend unbemerkt haben sie eine
Anpassung der Vorschriften der
grundbesitzbewertung auf den Weg
gebracht und was so harmlos klingt hat
massive Auswirkungen auf viele Haushalte
in diesem Land ja ich weiß dass die FDP
dass die FDP sich da getroffen führt ich
kann Ihnen nur sagen dann setzen sie
sich durch heben Sie die Freibeträge an
über Nacht wird sich jetzt der Sachwert
Faktor ändern damit beschließen sie und
das muss man sich vorstellen damit
beschließt auch faktisch die FDP eine
Steuererhöhung für viele Familien in
diesem Land obwohl sie das Versprechen
gegeben haben keine belastenden
Maßnahmen mehr für Menschen in unserem
Land durchzusetzen es kann nicht sein
dass Kinder das Eigenheim ihre Eltern
indem sie selber aufgewachsen sind nun
verkaufen müssen weil sie sich ihre
Erbschaftssteuer nicht leisten können
Steuern und Abgaben dürfen Steuern und
Abgaben dürfen kein treibender Faktor
dafür sein das Wohnungseigentum nicht
von einer Generation an die andere
übertragen werden kann wir fordern daher
als Union die massive Anhebung der
Freibeträge bei der Erbschaftssteuer
lassen sie mich zum Schluss kommen die
Ampel handelt nach dem Prinzip Hoffnung
sich verstricken sich in einem
ideologischen Knäuel deutschland kann
mehr wir lehnen ihre Pläne ab herzlichen
Dank
deutschland kann mehr sagt Michael
Breilmann und direkt darauf antworten
kann nun die zuständige Ministerin für
Wohnen Stadtentwicklung und Bauwesen
klarer sie sollte eigentlich früher
sprechen in dieser Debatte dann wurde
das aber verschoben unter anderem auch
wegen der vielen Presse Statements zum
Bürgergeld damit ihr jetzt die ganze
Aufmerksamkeit
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
Abgeordnete nein der einzige Plan 25 das
ist kein Knoll sondern das ist ein
riesiger Berg es ist nämlich gelungen
dass dieser Einzelplan die Ausgabe
Mittel des Bundes baumministeriums um
fast 50% erhöht wurden mehr als bei
allen anderen Ressorts und das Spiegel
ganz eindeutig eine Priorität der
Bundesregierung und der
koalitionsfraktion wieder
hierzu zählt
dass wir jetzt akut die Menschen
unterstützen durch das Wohngeld plus die
ganz dringend darauf angewiesen sind das
wurde bereits in der Debatte erwähnt der
Empfängerkreis von dreifacht sich und
doppelt so viel Geld pro Monat wird zur
Verfügung gestellt immerhin für 4,5
Milliarden Millionen Menschen für
Alleinerziehende für Familien mit
niedrigen Einkommen aber auch ganz
wichtig die Hälfte der
wohngeld-empfängerin sind Rentnerinnen
und Rentner und Sie haben ja über
Eigentum besprochen auch Menschen in
wohneigen Punkt können diese
Unterstützung die lassen Zuschuss
betragen damit sie in der Lage sind ihr
Haus zu halten und natürlich ist die
wohngeldreform die Verdreifachung des
bezugskreises eine starke Mehrbelastung
der Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter in
den wohngeldstellen deswegen bin ich
allen Abgeordneten dankbar die in den
letzten Wochen da waren und gezeigt
haben da wird wichtige Arbeit getan
Arbeit die kann konkret den Menschen
hilft in einer extrem schwierigen in
einer historischen Ausnahme Situation
und gemeinsam haben wir zusammen mit den
Kolleginnen in den Bundestag aber auch
im Bundesrat geschaut wie wir das
operationalisieren können wie wir diese
Reform gangbar machen können
entbürokratisieren und natürlich ist so
der Bewilligungszeitraum der ist von 12
auf 24 Monate verdoppelt worden und wir
haben auch jetzt die Möglichkeit mit
einem vorläufigen Bescheid zu arbeiten
damit viele Menschen nicht die Frage
stellen müssen essen oder heizen sondern
frühzeitig auch eine Unterstützung
bekommen und Herren sie kennen sich ja
in Berlin gut aus ich war auch in Berlin
im Wohnungsamt in Frankfurt oder wurde
mir gesagt in Berlin wird man in der
Lage sein auch schon im Januar zu
bescheiden
[Applaus]
und
Sie haben ja auch den Antrag aus dem
Bundesrat zitiert sie haben den Antrag
aus dem Bundesrat zitiert und was ist
denn da die Idee von Nordrhein-Westfalen
die Idee von Nordrhein-Westfalen ist das
Wohngeld nicht zum ersten ersten Kraft
treten zu lassen sondern zum ersten
vierten ja dadurch wird doch nichts
schneller das einzige was dadurch
passiert ist dass die Menschen nicht
rückwirkend ab 1.1 ihren Anspruch
erheben können und dann eine größere
Summe bezahlt bekommen wenn Ihr Antrag
verarbeitet wird sondern dass sie ihm
drei Monate Unterstützung wegnehmen wenn
Sie die wohngeldreform später in Kraft
treten lassen
wir tun viel dafür dass wir natürlich
auch den Bereich des sozialen
Wohnungsbaus und sie haben die
Entwicklung angesprochen erhöhen wir
arbeiten intensiv an der Einführung der
wohngemeinnützigkeit und wir starten ein
neues Förderprogramm um Familien mit
Kindern und natürlich Familien mit einem
kleinen Einkommen bei der Schaffung von
Wohneigentum zu unterstützen und die
große Herausforderung dieser Zeit ist
und bleibt bei allen anderen Belastungen
die wir zurzeit haben natürlich auch der
Klimawandel deswegen verbreitern wir
unseren Ansatz für fokussieren nicht
mehr nur auf die Frage der
Energieeffizienz sondern haben das
Qualitätssiegel nachhaltige Gebäude
entwickelt genau um das zu tun einen
nachhaltigen Gebäudebereich in
Deutschland zu schaffen und sie haben es
angesprochen das Bündnis für bezahlbarer
Wohnraum hat ein großes Paket entwickelt
und mir war immer von Anfang an wichtig
das ist nicht nur ein Tag im Kanzleramt
wo man zusammen kommt und ein schönes
Foto macht sondern ist der Prozess eines
Bearbeitungsvorgang ist wo wir alles
angucken was in Deutschland dazu führt
dass wir zu langsam zurzeit bauen und
dieser Prozess der geht schon Freitag
weiter mit der außerordentlichen
bauministerkonferenz weil wir machen das
natürlich mit den Ländern sie wissen
hier sind wesentliche Stellschrauben
über die Bauordnung und natürlich gibt
es viele Stimmen die sagen
Kostensteigerung Material Engpässe
Fachkräftemangel und natürlich jetzt
Einschränkungen durch den Krieg in der
Ukraine die 400.000 die werden wir
dieses Jahr nicht schaffen aber blicken
wir doch mal zurück ins letzte Jahr da
waren ganz viele dieser Einschränkungen
noch nicht und das letzte Jahr der alten
Regierung da waren wir auch bei unter
300.000 und deswegen sage ich wir haben
in Deutschland ein
produktivitätsproblem wir brauchen
dringend die Ausweitung der
baukapazitäten insgesamt weil in guten
und den schlechten Zeiten schaffen wir
es sonst nicht die notwendigen Wohnung
zu bauen das war das letzte Mal im Jahr
2000 wo wir es geschafft haben 400.000
Wohnungen zu bauen und das liegt
natürlich auch daran dass wir in dem
Bereich der Transformation der
Bauwirtschaft den letzten Jahren zu
wenig investiert haben Bauforschung
schauen Sie sich an wie wenig wir in
Bauforschung investieren angesichts des
gewaltigen Potenzials was wir hier haben
für CO2-Reduktion aber natürlich auch
den ganz ganz notwendigen Modernisierung
auch der Art und Weise wie wir mit
weniger Fachkräften in Zukunft mehr
bauen und eines ist mir ganz wichtig es
ist ein Punkt die Zusammenarbeit mit den
Städten und Gemeinden dieses Ministerium
ist ein kommunalministerium und Sie
haben ja gesagt wir hätten die 110
Millionen Euro gekürzt bei der
Städtebauförderung sie wissen genau
dieser Bundestag hat sich entschieden in
Zukunft anders die Förderung der
Sportstätten in den Kommunen zu machen
nämlich über das sjk-projekt und ich
habe so viele schreiben gekriegt auch
aus rein der Union dass ich weiß dass
Ihnen dieses Programm sehr sehr gut
bekannt ist also sprechen Sie bitte
nicht davon dass wir die Unterstützung
der Kommunen in dem Bereich reduziert
haben die deutlich erhoben
dazu gehört auch das ganz ganz wichtige
programmanpassung der urbanenräume an
den Klimawandel wir werden hitzinseln
sehen wir werden Starkregenereignisse
sehen und wir lassen die Kommunen nicht
unter alleine bei der Anpassung ich
danke dem Parlament dass wir erneut
wieder Mittel bekommen haben für den
barrierefreien Umbau und bin ganz
hoffnungsvoll dass wir das beim nächsten
Regierungsentwurf schaffen dass wir das
auch gleich dem Wunsch des Parlament
Folgen von vornherein mit reinnehmen ich
danke auch
den Abgeordneten die an die gedacht
haben die keine Wohnung haben an die
Obdachlosen an die Wohnungslosen ist es
gut dass diese Bundesregierung dass
dieses Parlament ein großer
Aufmerksamkeit hat für dieses wichtige
Themen wurden es ein Menschenrecht und
es gibt immer noch zu viele in
Deutschland die dieses Menschenrecht
nicht leben können keine Wohnung haben
hier müssen wir dringend anpacken und
ich weiß das sind ganz viele engagiert
in den Kommunen die darauf warten dass
wir grundlegende Fragen wie Zugang zu
Krankenversicherung auch ansprechen weil
wir viel über Städte gesprochen haben
als Brandenburgerin liegt mir sehr am
Herzen zu sagen wir sind nicht nur das
Ministerium für die großen Metropolen
sondern auch für den ländlichen Raum und
natürlich auch für die kleinen Städte
die in diesem ländlichen Raum ganz
wesentliche Ankerfunktion haben und
deswegen freut es mich dass wir auch die
Arbeit der Kleinstadt Akademie auf ganz
neuem Niveau ausbauen können und hier
den Best Practice den Austausch der so
wichtigen Kommunen und einander
stärken können und natürlich als
raumordnungsministerin ist in der
Zusammenhalt in Deutschland sehr sehr
wichtig deswegen ist es schön dass mein
Ministerium helfen kann auch das
zukunftszentrum deutsche Einheit und
europäische Transformation mit unserer
baufachlichen Expertise auch bei der so
wichtigen Standortsuche zu fragen zu
fördern sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
insgesamt setzen wir also mit diesem
Haushalt beherzt an den drei drängenden
gesellschaftlichen Fragen an bezahlbarer
Wohnraum für möglichst viele ein
innovatives klimafreundliches Bauwesen
und lebenswerte Städte und Gemeinden und
bei aller strittigen Debatte bedanke ich
mich für die gute Zusammenarbeit mit den
allermeisten Fraktionen herzlichen Dank
mit den allermeisten Fraktionen Susann
Clara galwitz und das muss man ja auch
sagen dass es hier im Parlament dann
doch oft etwas hitziger zugeht als in
den Arbeitssitzungen der Ausschüsse das
hören wir schon mal Listen zumindest
dabei sein können wir eigentlich nicht
Roger backkamp spricht jetzt für die
afd-fraktion Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren alles wird teurer nur
Häuser und Wohnungen werden plötzlich
zumindest etwas billiger das verwundert
zunächst ist das Bauen in der Zeit doch
massiv teurer geworden und auch die
Kaufangebote auf dem Wohnungsmarkt nimmt
zu auch das verwundert ist doch die Zahl
der Baugenehmigungen für neue Wohnung in
Deutschland deutlich eingebrochen in der
Tat sind derzeit mehr Wohnungen und
Häuser auf dem Markt das allerdings
immer noch auf einem sagenhaft hohen
Preisniveau aber zumindest steigen die
Preise erst einmal nicht weiter
ist das ein Ergebnis guter Bau und
Wohnungspolitik damit sich viele
Menschen den Traum von eigenen vier
Wänden erfüllen können nein leider nein
leider gar nicht wirklich freuen könnte
ich über diese Entwicklung die wenigsten
nur die die schon viel Geld haben oder
sehr gut verdienen eine eigene Immobilie
ist für die meisten Menschen in unserem
Land unerreichbarer denn je denn Ursache
des größeren Angebots ist eben nicht der
sehr viel mehr gebaut worden wäre
sondern es ist länger dauert bis Käufer
gefunden sind und gleichzeitig werden
immer mehr Bauprojekte eingestellt eine
stornierungswelle in der Baubranche ist
im folgenange Zitat
angesichts der oft kaum mehr
kalkulierbaren Baukosten und rasch
steigenden Bauzinsen werfen viele
Bauherren das Handtuch sie stellen
Projekte zurück oder streichen sie ganz
so dass Ifo-Institut die Erwartung der
Baubranche notieren auf dem tiefsten
Stand seit Beginn der Erhebung im Jahre
1991 die meisten Menschen können es
einfach nicht mehr bezahlen und wir
machen viele Bauunternehmen zunächst
einfach mal
die Hoffnung auf bezahlbares
Wohneigentum für eine deutschen und
Einheimischen hat diese Regierung haben
sie ausgeknipst und das ist gerade zu
zwangsläufig wenn die Einnahmen der
meisten Leute in unserem Land gleich
bleiben aber die Zinsen für Immobilien
Darlehen massiv steigen diese Zinsen
haben sich in den letzten Monaten
vervierfacht von gut einem Prozent zu
Anfang des Jahres auf jetzt 4 %. grund
dafür ist die Inflation ihre Inflation
die von ihnen verschulte Inflation muss
runter und solange das nicht der Fall
ist müssen sich müssen die Menschen in
unserem Land von Kosten entlastet und
ihn zugleich geholfen werden finanzielle
Hürden beim Eigentumserwerb zu
überwinden gute Ideen gute Ideen da
können sie gerne zwischen möchten gute
Ideen dafür gibt es genug hatten Sie ja
selbst schon mal
es war vorgesehen bei Ihnen den
Bundesländern zu ermöglichen die
Grunderwerbsteuer flexibel zur Hand
haben also etwa Freibeträge für
Selbstnutzer
diese Regierung hatte selbst einmal
vorgesehen Eigenkapital ersetzte
Darlehen einzuführen damit Haushalte
leichter Wohneigentum erwerben können
das wäre in der Tat eine Wohnungspolitik
die ihren Namen verdient das wäre auch
eine Haushaltspolitik zu ganzen
zugunsten des eigenen Volkes das wären
alles Wege die vielen Menschen den Weg
zu Wohneigentum erleichtern alles
versprechen dieser Regierung übrigens
auch der Vorgängerregierung passiert ist
damals nicht und heute auch
auch Ideen wird für eine
hypothekenversicherung also eine
staatliche immobilienkreditversicherung
wie in Niederlanden und wie vom Institut
der deutschen Wirtschaft vorgeschlagen
wäre ein weiterer Schritt aber das hat
für Sie hier keine Priorität das fehlt
im Haushalt eben alles nicht statt es
bleibt die Frage wie soll eine Familie
das bezahlen aber sie widmen sich lieber
ihrem Lieblingsprojekt Geld der
Steuerzahler an Leute zu verteilen die
absehbar nichts zu unserem Land
beitragen und damit meine ich
ausnahmsweise bei nicht nur
asylforderung aus Afrika und den Nahen
Osten sondern z.B auch die Milliarde für
das Bundeskanzleramt und das ist
konservativ gestärkt sich wer mit ihnen
1,5 mindestens Frau Ministerin niemand
verlangt von Ihnen dass Sie Wohnungen
bauen aber in Rahmen müssen sie richtig
setzen und das Geld an die richtigen
Leute verteilen bauen werden dann schon
andere aber genau das machen sie nicht
und vielleicht wollen sie das auch nicht
Eigentum ist verdächtig Eigentum ist
Freiheit und dass sie ihr Problem
es bleibt die Erkenntnis wer mit einem
mittleren Einkommen ein Haus kaufen
möchte in diesem Land wird auf ein Erbe
oder das Ende der Inflation hoffen
müssen oder am besten auf das Ende
dieser Regierung
soweit die Meinung der
afd-fraktion unter anderem auch über die
Ursachen warum es in Deutschland eine
Inflation gibt Kassen
ob man im Ausschuss für Wohnstadt
Entwicklung Bauweise und Kommunen für
die Grünen Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren liebe Gäste ich
möchte heute meine Zeit etwas effektiver
nutzen und nicht auf dem Märchenstunde
der AFD eingehen
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren mein Bild
von einer gelungenen bauwände sieht wie
folgt aus Häuser die von oben bis nach
unten begrün sind mit Efeu an den
Fassaden und Gras auf den Dächern so
schön die Vorstellung ist dieses Gras
fängt nicht plötzlich an zu wachsen
damit die Pflanzen auch gedeihen können
braucht es einen Nährboden eine
Grundlage
und das ist diese Haushalt das schafft
Grundlagen erstens Grundlagen für
bezahlbares Wohnraum und gegen die
Wohnungslosigkeit
zweitens Grundlagen in der Forschung
damit weitere Lösungswege gefunden
werden um die viel zu hohen Emissionen
im Gebäudesektor zu minimieren und
drittens
und drittens Grundlagen für eine
wärmewende die mit Blick auf diesen und
weiteren Winter auch tatsächlich
angegangen wird meine Damen und Herren
die Kälte ist nun endgültig angekommen
und eine Bevölkerungsgruppe hat die
nächsten Monate besonders hart zu
kämpfen Menschen die von Obdach und
Wohnungslosigkeit betroffen sind der
Aktionsplan gegen die Obdachlosigkeit
ist ein wichtiges Projekt dieser Ampel
ich bin froh dass die Grundlage auch
dafür durch im Haushalt durch unsere
Haushälter Markus Korb Thorsten Herbst
Uwe Schmidt auch gelegt sind denn das
Recht
denn das Recht meine Damen und Herren
auf obwohl es ein Menschenrecht noch ein
weiteres Vorhaben aus dem
Koalitionsvertrag wurde im Haushalt 23
übersetzt die Neubauförderung für die
schweren Haushalte damit fördert der
Bund künftig
energieeffiziente Eigenheime wir sollten
uns dabei nicht auf den
energieintensiven Neubau versteifen
stattdessen sollten auch Gelder in den
Umbau zu schaffen von Eigenheimen
fließen vielleicht kann ich die
Ministerin auch davon noch überzeugen
aber ihre Rede hat sie das ganz klar
betont Neubau ist wichtig nicht dazu
trotz müssen wir auf den Bestand gehen
nicht nur in urbanengebieten sondern
auch im ländlichen Raum
denn der größte Brocken ist die graue
Energie beim Baum eines unterkellerten
drei geschossigen Mehrfamilienhauses in
Massivbauweise entstehen pro
Quadratmeter 800 bis 900 Kilogramm CO2
also pro Quadratmeter so viel wie ein
Flug von Berlin nach Katar ich würde
heute noch mal pro Quadratmeter
wir müssen also dringend und viel mehr
jetzt darauf schauen welche
Baumaterialien eigentlich wir bauen die
Bauforschung hat in diesem Feld schon
viel geleistet es ist gut und wichtig
dass Innovationsprogramm Zukunft Bau mit
jetzt fast 4,8 Millionen Euro
aufzustocken
gleichzeitig muss aber auch Forschung
auch die Umsetzung kommen wir wissen
schon lange wie wir mit nachwachsenden
Rohstoffen wie z.B dem Holz auch bauen
das heißt ist ja auch die nationale
Holzbau Strategie im Koalitionsvertrag
bereits vereinbart wir Bündnis grüne
werden ökologische Baustoffe weiter
pushen auch ohne die entsprechenden
Gelder im Haushalt 23
zuletzt schaffen wir mit diesem Haushalt
viele wichtige Grundlagen für die
wärmewende wir haben es jetzt schwarz
auf weiß diese Bundesregierung hat es
verstanden dass das auf dem Bestand
ankommt ich und viele andere sagen es
immer wieder wir müssen an unsere
energetisch schlechtesten gedämmten
Gebäude rein 13 Milliarden Euro
13 Milliarden Euro allein ist für den
Haushalt 23 bereits vereinbart für die
Sanierungsförderung und damit
tatsächlich auch mehr saniert wird
braucht es eine flächendeckende
Energieberatung und qualifizierte
Fachkräfte
dass das Aufbauprogramm Wärmepumpe hat
sogar einen eigenen Titel das ist auch
gut so und kurbelt die wärmewende
weiterhin an
meine Damen und Herren dieser Haushalt
schafft an vielen Stellen einen
lehrreichen Boden für den
sozialökologischen Wandel unseres Landes
unserer Nation indem wir nämlich
investieren investieren in die
wärmewende investieren in die Forschung
investieren in die soziale Gerechtigkeit
diesen Nährboden zu bepflanzen das muss
unsere gemeinsame Aufgabe sein lassen
Sie uns gemeinsam die bauwände angehen
vielen Dank
Lob von
Koalitionspartner der Grünen unter
anderem für den ökologischen Aspekt hier
in diesem Etat der Gebäude bestand soll
nach Willen der Bundesregierung bis zum
Jahr 2045 klimaneutral werden dafür
müsste es noch einige Umbauten geben
Ulrich lange spricht nun für die
Unionsfraktion
gute Kollegen nach einem Jahr Ampel nach
einem Jahr nach eigenes
baumministerium Frau Ministerin müssen
wir leider konstatieren das ist ein
verlorenes Jahr war und wenn sie an das
Jahr 2000 mit 400.000 Wohnungen erinnern
dann erinnere ich sie dass das das Ende
der Regierung cool war mit dem eigenen
baumministerium unter Eduard Oswald sie
können aber gerne an diese Historie
versuchen anzuknüpfen Frau Ministerin
es nützt nichts weiter Luft und
Traumschlösser zu bauen und von diesen
400.000 Wohnungen zu reden oder zu
träumen oder Gipfel oder Bündnisse in
welchen Räumen des Kanzleramtes oder
Ministeriums auch immer abzuhalten fakt
ist
fakt ist dass wir zehn Prozent weniger
Baugenehmigungen haben das heißt wir
werden definitiv auf einen weiteren
Rückgang im Wohnungsbau zu steuern liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und was tun sie
dagegen eine
wohnungseigentumsförderung die ihren
Namen eigentlich nicht einmal verdient
350 Millionen Euro im Jahr sind es dann
tatsächlich da mag man jetzt über das
Baukindergeld reden aber das
Baukindergeld waren zehn Milliarden
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen 10
Milliarden für
300.000 Familien die
da die ihren Traum leben konnten vom
Eigenheim die als Familie glücklich auch
in einem energetischen in einem schönen
Häuschen mit Garten heute glücklich als
Familie leben das ist Union das ist
Gesellschaftspolitik das ist Baupolitik
und das ist Familienpolitik aus einem
Guss
und was sie jetzt produzieren ist doch
nichts anderes als neuer Frust nach
ihrem ganzen förderchaos diesen Jahres
sie haben dieses Baukindergeld auch noch
vorzeitig gestoppt und lieber Kollege
von den Grünen wenn ich sie jetzt gerade
gehört habe vom grünen begrasten Efeu
umrankten Haus dann muss ich schon ganz
offen sagen mit all den Baustoffen die
sie dort verbauen möchten es sollte bei
aller energietischen
Wohlfühlatmosphäre für die Menschen und
für die Familien mit normalen Einkommen
auch noch bezahlbar bleiben und darum
geht es uns als Union auch jeder wenn es
ein Menschenrecht ist hat jeder den
Anspruch auf eine warme Wohnung und das
ist das worum es uns primär geht liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Wohneigentum dient der privaten
Vermögensbildung und schützt vor
Altersarmut mieten Politik und
wohnungseigentumspolitik müssen immer
zusammen gedacht werden das lässt sich
nicht trennen und eigentlich dachten wir
mal dass die FDP das auch wüsste liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
lassen Sie mich noch zwei drei Sätze zu
den Kommunen sagen lieber Kollege
Daldrup ich schätze sie wirklich als
Politiker aus der kommunalen Familie
aber sie wissen und sie haben natürlich
die Stellungnahme des Bundesrates und
damit auch ihre eigenen Länder Kollegen
ganz genau gelesen sie wissen natürlich
dass das Wohngeld plus so nicht
umsetzbar ist in den Kommunen so schnell
können Sie das Personal gar nicht finden
dass sie brauchen für Wohngeld für
Bürger Geld für 49 Euro Ticket allein
bei mir im Landkreis brauchen wir 30
neue Stellen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die können wir nicht von der
Straße holen die sind nicht da sie
versprechen etwas was in der Realität
der Kommune der Kommunalpolitik
scheitert und das ist unrechtlich den
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern gegenüber
gleiches gilt gleiches gilt für die
Städtebauförderung
790 Millionen das ist am Ende deutlich
weniger die 790 Millionen haben wir die
ganze Zeit schon fortgeschrieben gehabt
bei der Steigerung der Preise haben die
Kommunen damit weniger Geld für
tatsächliche Umsetzung von Maßnahmen das
ist einfach Teil von Wahrheit und
Lebenswirklichkeit liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und das betrifft auch die
nationalen Projekte durch Städtebaus der
Kollege hat sich von angesprochen
Leuchttürme würden sie das Geld das sie
jetzt einsetzen für den Erweiterungsbau
des Bundeskanzleramts in die Leuchttürme
der nationalen Projekte der Städtebaus
einsetzen dann hätte das ganze Land viel
gewonnen und die Möglichkeit dazu haben
wir Ihnen gegeben liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
denn
denn entgegen denn entgegen dem was was
Kolleginnen und Kollegen hier dieser
ampelfraktionen in der letzten Debatte
behauptet haben haben wir im
Haushaltsausschuss Maßgabe Beschlüsse
vorgelegt das Kanzleramt zu verkleinern
es zu verschieben die Zeiten Wände darf
an der Tür des Kanzleramts nicht enden
das kann nicht sein Herr Bundeskanzler
denn diese Form von Fake News über uns
als Union an dieser Stelle in der
letzten Debatte weiß ich hier noch mal
zurück liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
kaufen Sie für
kaufen Sie sie
wohnen beim Wohngeld stattdessen eine
schuldenoffensive einer
funktionsgestörten ampelregierung danke
schön
Ulrich lange war das der
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzender
der Unionsfraktion es geht hier
natürlich viel um den energetischen
Sanierungsbedarf und damit wird ja auch
Energie gespart das versucht übrigens
auch der Bundestag und sie sehen hier
auch die Ministerin sitzt hier im dicken
Schal denn es gab einen Konzept mit dem
Titel Einsparung von Energie beim
Gebäudebetrieb des Deutschen Bundestags
in dem
Bundestagspräsidentin Bärbel Bars
vorgeschlagen hat dass hier im
Plenarsaal maximal nur noch auf 20 Grad
geheizt wird und das sehen wir doch hier
bei einigen Abgeordneten und ich weiß
auch von unseren Kamera Leuten das ist
ein bisschen frischer heute ist fangen
Reinhold jetzt für die fdpressionen
ansprechen ja das haben sie ja 16 Jahre
gehegt gepflegt und gegossen jetzt
stehen sie am Rand und schauen zu und
beschimpfen noch diejenigen die
Heckenscheren die hat immer diesen
Vorschriften angehen wollen das ist
unredlich eh voll Weg
übrigens auch ganz kostenlos und von
allein und am besten finde ich alles
zwei Redner von ihnen der Meinung waren
dass der Auftragseinbruch und der
genehmigungsrückgang ernsthaft mit dem
Baukindergeld zu tun habe ich bin
Maurermeister selbst ein Bauunternehmen
wir haben der Zinsentwicklung die es
zurzeit besorgniserregend wir haben
materialpreisengpässe noch und Löcher
wir haben Lieferketten die
zusammenbrechen wir haben viel zu wenig
Facharbeiter das sind die Gründe warum
die Baufirmen zur Zeit Not haben aber
mit Sicherheit nicht wegen ihrem
Baukindergeld das im übrigen März 21
schon endete und weil wir
und weil wir ja in der Ampel einen
anderen Blick auf die Welt haben nämlich
einen realistischen die mache ich mal
mit dem realistischen Blick weiter und
der ist eben nicht jeder wohnt in einem
schönen Neubau am besten am See
bodengleiche Duschen ein Fahrstuhl drin
eine gut abgestimmte Heizung mit
erneuerbaren Energien nein in diesem
Land sind 70% der Häuser von 1990 gebaut
und da sehen die Häuser etwas anders aus
da brauche ich schon drei vier Stufen
bevor ich ins Haus reinkomme
wahrscheinlich noch eine ganze Etage
wird ins Bad zu kommen ich gehe durch 73
cm Robert richtmast für durch durch die
ich wieder mit dem Rollstuhl noch mit
einer Gehhilfe kommen und landen ein
Badezimmer mit einer gemauerten
Badewanne wo ich kaum dran vorbeikomme
deshalb weil wir auf die Realitäten
kommen haben wir 70 Millionen dieses
Jahr 75 Millionen in den Beratung
übrigens insgesamt noch mit oben drauf
gelegt damit wir altersgerechte Umbauten
fördern damit wir die Leute
in ihrem letzten Lebensabschnitt in
ihren eigenen vier Wänden lassen weil
uns es wichtig ist dass die Menschen in
ein Heim kommen wo sie Wärme und Liebe
finden und das ist bei sich zu Hause und
deshalb gehen wir als Ampel dieses
Problem an 20 Prozent der Bevölkerung
sind über 67 12 Millionen wurden
Eigentümer sind über 60 Jahre weil uns
all das bekannt ist gehen wir es an
genauso wie die Realität bedeutet wenn
ich nicht nur das vorschriftende
bekämpfen will sondern die Kosten fürs
Wohnen und fürs Bauen senken will
brauche ich Forschung und Entwicklung
neue Baumaterialien neue Baustoffe
deshalb vor stärken wir die Bauforschung
deshalb brauche ich Maßnahmen wie ich
die Bauwirtschaft Anreize in dieser
Situation weiterzubauen die Ministerin
hat zu Recht ausgeführt das in diesen
schweren Zeiten es trotzdem gelingt dass
die Bauten so hochzuhalten wie sie jetzt
gerade sind wir verschließen nicht die
Augen vor der Wahrheit wie sie wir gehen
an und das mit Maßnahmen wo wir nicht
viel Geld in Schau feststellen was sie
ja zu Recht heute wieder versucht haben
hier vorzu zeigen sondern wie wir mit
klugen Beschlüssen das
haushaltsausschlusses die auch noch
verlangen dass man berichterstattet wie
es Geld ausgegeben worden ist ob wir CO2
wirklich einsparen das ist eine kluge
Haushaltsführung in diesem Land in dem
wir nämlich endlich dazu kommen das
Fördermittel aufgelegt werden die auch
umgesetzt werden und diesem Land helfen
hier helfen wir dem Land da schreiben
wir heute nur
nächste Rednerin ist Mächte Teil für die
cdu/cs
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich möchte
gegen Ende der Debatte zu unserem
schönen Einzelband 25 einmal festhalten
es ist wirklich schön dass es diesen
Plan gibt das haben wir baupolitiker mit
unserer Arbeit in der letzten Periode
erreicht und das wird auch den Problemen
in unserem Land wirklich gerecht in der
Gesamtschau da bin ich ehrlich ist der
Einzelfall 25 finanziell auch durchaus
nicht schlecht ausgestattet schwierig
was das allerdings wenn man dann in die
Details schaut da sieht man dass es in
nur zwei Bereichen erhebliche Mittel
gibt nämlich einmal für den sozialen
Wohnungsbau mal gespannt was daraus wird
und beim viel besprochenen Wohngeld
und der restliche Etat das ist echt
Brachland ödes dürres Brachland
ungenützte Fläche und sie blicken eben
nicht in die Zukunft mit ihrem
Einzelplan
bei der Stelle Überforderung verweisen
sie stolz darauf dass sie Mittel in Höhe
von 790 Millionen Euro verstetigen
würden was heißt das denn genau diese
Summe steht so ungefähr seit Jahren in
den bundeshaushalten aber die Baupreise
steigen ja nun seit einem Jahr immer
schneller und der Gesamtumfang des
Haushaltes des Bundeshaushalts auch also
was sie in Wirklichkeit machen ist wenn
sie von verstetigen sprechen sie kürzen
die Städtebauförderung real natürlich
wissen sie das ich frage mich warum
sagen Sie es eigentlich nicht haben Mut
dazu
es findet sich auch keine finanzielle
kraftvolle Gestaltung im Bereich von
Digitalisierung nichts um die Länder und
Kommune bei der Digitalisierung im
Bereich von Planen von Genehmigungen von
Bauten zu unterstützen dabei liegen
gerade da ja die erheblichen Potenziale
auf die gerade auch immer die
Wohnungswirtschaft wieder Hinweisen
digital first liebe Kollegen von der FDP
das darf eben nicht nur ein Schlagwort
sein und sie Frau Ministerin müssen
deshalb deutlich mehr Geld auch in
diesen Bereich in die Hand nehmen
und sie wollen Frau Ministerin das
400.000 neue Wohnungen errichtet werden
in einem Jahr zu geben eine Maße
schwierigen Marktumfeld und kürzlich
haben sie deswegen auch das Bündnis für
bezahlbares Wohnung wohnen in Seben
gerufen und die haben ihre Ideen
vorgestellt ehrlich gesagt viele der
Ideen die schon sind schon ziemlich alt
vieles was sie da gesagt haben ist
regulatorischer Art aber der Kern liegt
doch daran sie übersehen geflissentlich
bauen kostet nun mal Geld natürlich in
erster Linie das Geld der Investoren und
der Bauherr aber ohne eine substanzielle
staatliche Förderung werden sie ihr Ziel
mehr zu bauen nicht erreichen können und
was tun sie nun anstatt zu fördern und
Geld in die Hand zu nehmen fallen sie
mit einem förderchaos
aufzugebendermaßen das müssen sie sich
jetzt nicht anheften sondern ihr Kollege
der die für das Federführung hat der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister
2023 wenn sie im Bauministerium für die
Neubauförderung nun verantwortlich sein
aber wo bleibt denn dann in diesem
Haushalt wirklich der finanzielle
Anschub für den Wohnungsbau nur eine
Milliarde Euro stehen verteilt über alle
Programme im Haushalt zur Verfügung das
ist nun wirklich kein kraftvoller an
Schub für uns sondern in Feigenblatt
wichtiges Thema in unserem
Arbeitsbereich ist auch das mittlerweile
sehr teure Bauland das stellen sie in
den Redebeiträgen auch immer wieder fest
was könnte man da nicht alles machen sie
könnten die Kommunen zum Beispiel beim
Bodenmanagement finanziell unterstützen
wir könnten ein tragflächenprogramm
auflegen kraftvolle Programme für 2023
aber alles nichts Fehlanzeige gähnende
Lehrerin nur mit reden
nur mit Reden und konzeptpapieren lässt
sich kein Bauland aktivieren fast hat
man den Anschein sie wollen gar kein
neues baulandausweisen sind sie da von
den Grünen mit Nasenring durch die
Manege getragen worden man weiß es nicht
auch im Einzelplan auch in den
Einzelmaßnahmen ist ihr finanzielles
Engagement begrenzt wir haben eben schon
davon geredet altersgerechte Umbau wir
haben einen Antrag gestellt
Einbruchschutz alles erfolgreiche
Förderprogramme der letzten
Bundesregierung bei ihnen müssen wir
dann als baupolitiker um jeden Cent
kämpfen leider meistens sehr erfolglos
aber beneide ich jetzt die Kollegen von
der Ampel-Koalition nicht sie wollen Sie
wahrscheinlich mal Mitleid nicht ich
kann nur hoffen dass es in den nächsten
Jahren besser wird und Frau Ministerin
sie haben das angekündigt im Jahre 24
danach zulegen
und nicht nur für den Einzelnen 25
sondern für den gesamten Bundeshaushalt
relevant ist auch das Thema bundesbau
hier wird tatsächlich einiges gestaltet
und dann Geld investiert und
ausgerechnet dieser Bereich soll nun
nach dem Willen der Ampelkoalition in
wesentlichen Teilen aus dem aus ihrem
Verantwortungsbereich des
Bauministeriums rausgehen in das
Finanzministerium
da liegt ja wirklich nur mal der Gedanke
nach was bleibt denn dann eigentlich im
Bauministerium ist das dann die reine
mangelverwertung die die die sie noch
haben ich frag mich wirklich was das
soll aber einfach können Sie in der
Ernte geben
wenn wir es eben auch schon mal kurz
angesprochen haben ich würde auch gerne
mal darauf eingehen Bundeskanzleramt ja
wir haben das mit beschlossen damals
aber damals war die Welt eine andere
allerdings heute sind die Baukosten viel
höhere und wir sagen es ist wirklich
heute angemessen dass wir die sich das
noch mal angucken nach dass man nach den
Einsparpotenzialen sucht und prüft ob
der bauzeitpunkt jetzt wirklich so sein
muss oder ob man das nicht noch einmal
verschieben kann
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen zum
Schluss möchte ich sagen Frau Ministerin
wir wissen dass ihr Ministerium noch
nicht gut aufgestellt ist dass es noch
viele Planstellen gibt die noch nicht
besetzt sind aber ich lege ihn wirklich
ans Herzen setzen Sie sich in dem
Eisenbahn im nächsten Jahr 24 gegen
ihren Finanzminister deutlich härter
durch das tut allen im Land gut und vor
allen Dingen den Leuten die bauen wollen
vielen Dank
Mechthild Heil hier mit einer doch recht
resignierten Rede zum Einzelplan 25 von
bundesbauministerin Clara gaiwitz andere
Töne dürfte die nächste Rednerin an
stoßen Franziska Maschek für die
SPD-Fraktion sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin sehr geehrte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
ich bin ein kleines bisschen irritiert
wir haben hier eine Debatte wo gerade
die gesamte Haushaltsverhandlungen die
wir gemeinsam geführt haben so mit
falschen Tatsachen Verdrehungen und
Verkürzungen einfach irgendwie in der
Luft zerrissen wird wissen Sie ich komme
aus Ostdeutschland ja wir brauchen ein
bisschen Vertrauen in die Demokratie und
wenn ihr so eine seltsame Debatte
stattfindet die einfach in den Fakten
falsch ist die einfach verkürzt ist dann
mache ich mir wirklich Sorgen wie wir
gemeinsam wie wir gemeinsam auch nach
draußen transportieren wollen dass wir
hier eine unglaubliche Arbeit leisten in
der wir die Probleme anpacken gucken was
ist notwendig und nach vorne gehen und
ja dieses kleine Bisschen Haushalt macht
sich eben nicht von alleine wir
Parlamentarierinnen und Parlamentarier
müssen jedes Mal dafür streiten und
richtig kämpfen und besonders jetzt wo
diese Folgen dieses russischen
Angriffskrieges sich in jedem Haushalt
zeigen müssen wir gucken dass wir die
Balance finden zwischen erstens der
Herausforderung be zeigen und zweitens
aber auch in die Zukunft zu investieren
und die Kosten fürs Wohnen für den
gesamten Bausektor sind gestiegen schon
die ganze Zeit gestiegen das war
deswegen haben wir im Koalitionsvertrag
schon den Heizkostenzuschuss vereinbart
und die wohngeldreform vereinbart und
genau diese Dinge haben wir auch
umgesetzt Liebe Union
[Applaus]
die Kunst ist also die Balance zu halten
zwischen einerseits bezahlbaren wohnen
und andererseits der Investitionen in
die Zukunft und dass meine Damen und
Herren macht sich eben nicht von allein
und deswegen danke ich den Kolleginnen
und Kollegen in den Ausschüssen im
Haushaltsausschuss sowie auch deren
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern die
mit ganz großen Engagement diesen 13 Akt
wirklich gemeistert haben
einbaustein ist das Massiv ausgebaute
Wohngeld mit 2,9 Milliarden Euro damit
helfen wir Menschen mit wenig und sehr
wenig Einkommen unter ihnen sind
besonders viele Menschen in
Ostdeutschland und es sind Rentnerinnen
und Rentner und es sind besonders auch
Familien ich freue mich über das neue
Programm Förderprogramm für Wohneigentum
für Familien weiß genau da ansetzt wo es
uns wichtig ist Familien mit wenig
Einkommen Familie mit mittleren
Einkommen
Bundesministerin Clara Gallwitz hat es
angekündigt dafür sind 350 Millionen
Euro im Haushalt ja und es hilft genau
an dieser Stelle auch dass wir mehr
Menschen in Ostdeutschland unterstützen
wo die Löhne und Vermögen seit 32 Jahren
nach der Wiedervereinigung immer noch
niedriger sind als in Westdeutschland
das ist ein weiterer kleiner Baustein
für gleichwertige Lebensverhältnisse und
was ich besonders begrüße
ist das das sehr gut gelaufen ist würde
jetzt auch schon mehrmals erwähnt gut
gelaufene Förderprogramm altersgerechter
Umbau noch einmal mehr Geld bekommen hat
als es ursprünglich der Haushalt vorsah
denn auch damit unterstützen wir ältere
Menschen die in ihren eigenen vier
Wänden bleiben möchten und dafür eben
ein paar Anpassungen brauchen all das
macht sich nicht von allein aber liebe
Union und lieber Herr Reimann sie haben
mehr Geld dafür gefordert aber was sie
wollten ist das Geld vom sozialen
Wohnungsbau nehmen und irgendwie ist das
komisch von den Ärmsten das Geld
wegnehmen um es den anderen zu gehen zu
geben so geht soziale Gerechtigkeit ganz
sicher nicht liebe Union sowas machen
Sie bitte schön alleine
und ja
auch ich hätte sehr gerne neue
Haushaltsmittel für das Programm
nationale Projekte der
Städtebauförderung gesehen tatsächlich
aber angesichts der Herausforderung im
Haushalt das ist mir doch viel lieber
das Geld kommt bei den Familien an bei
Seniorinnen und Senioren bei jungen
Menschen und Menschen die Unterstützung
brauchen
wir haben 13,8 Milliarden Euro für den
energetischen für die energetische
Sanierung im Gebäudebestand es ist nicht
unser Haushalt aber es sind Gebäude die
dringend angepasst werden müssen
hingegen unser Haus stellt das Geld für
die Kommunen zur Verfügung die Kommunen
können in der Stadt Entwicklung und das
ist mir das wissen sie ein sehr
wichtiges Thema genau diese Dinge
anpassen für Sport Jugend und Kultur
außerdem ermöglichen die Maßnahmen damit
Städte besser vor Hitze und stark gegen
geschützt werden und sich dort anpassen
können dafür stehen insgesamt 700
Millionen Euro zur Verfügung alles das
sind wichtige Maßnahmen um eine sozial
gerechtere und ökologische ökologische
Welt von morgen zu bauen und all das
macht sich nicht von alleine dafür
dürfen und müssen wir in der Demokratie
gemeinsam bringen vielen Dank und ein
herzliches Glück auch
Franziska Maschek war das ein nächster
Redner ist Sebastian Münzenmaier der
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzender
der afd-fraktion Präsidentin meine Damen
und Herren wir nähern uns im Jahrestag
dieser Bundesregierung und wir nähern
uns auch dem Jahrestag des neu
gegründeten Bauministeriums groß
angekündigt mit vielen Stellen
ausgestattet und vor wichtige Aufgaben
gestellt waren wir glaube ich hier alle
im Haus gespannt welche bahnbrechenden
Erfolge in Zukunft von Ministerin
geibels verkündet werden können 400 000
neue Wohnungen im Jahr war das Ziel der
Bundesregierung dazu Bürokratie Abbau
vereinfachte Verfahren schnellere
Genehmigung und insgesamt einfach
weniger wohnungsnoten Deutschland wie
sind wie sieht denn ihre Bilanz ein Jahr
später aus erstens anstatt 400.000
Wohnungen werden im Jahr 2022
wahrscheinlich nur ungefähr 200.000
Wohnungen gebaut Haus und Grund geht
sogar davon aus dass man in den nächsten
Jahren sogar weniger als 100.000
Wohnungen pro Jahr baut das nennt man
Drachen gescheiter meine Damen und
Herren
zweitens anstatt für vereinfachte
Verfahren für eine bessere Unterstützung
zu sorgen hat die Bundesregierung die
KfW-Förderung über Nacht gestoppt und so
völlig abrupt bei vielen Bürgern den
Traum vom Eigenheim beerdigt 3 anstatt
für bezahlbaren Wohnraum zu sorgen haben
sie mit ihrer unsinnigen Energiepolitik
die Nebenkosten noch weiter in die Höhe
getrieben und gehen jetzt ganz aktuell
noch so weit dass sie die vielen kleinen
Vermieter in Zukunft auch noch durch
eine CO2-Steuer also durch die anteilige
CO2 Steuer zusätzlich belasten wollen
sie haben es also in 12 Monaten
geschafft dass wir weniger Wohnungen wie
vorher gebaut haben weniger Menschen
haben Förderung erhalten und weniger
Vermieter werden in Zukunft die eigene
Wohnung überhaupt noch vermieten und der
normalen Umständen würden man diese
Bilanz als katastrophal bezeichnen aber
in dieser Bundesregierung fällt Versagen
schlicht und ergreifen nicht mehr weiter
auf meine Damen und Herren
sie dürfen gerne Zwischenfrage stellen
wenn sie so dazwischen rein Blöcken
melden sich doch stellen sie zwischen
ihre Frage wie das unter anständigen
Demokraten so der Usus ist und dann gebe
ich Ihnen auch gerne Antwort darauf sie
schaffen es also nicht auf der
Angebotsseite Wohnraum zu generieren
aber was mit der Nachfrage seid und
jetzt dürfen sie gleich wieder
weiterschreiben und sie wollen sich
hören dass mir bewusst aber es ist eben
für unseren Wohnungsmarkt ein riesiges
Problem dass jedes Jahr hunderttausende
Migranten nach Deutschland einwandern
und auf den Wohnungsmarkt drängen wenn
im ersten Halbjahr 2022 eine Million
Menschen einwandert dann sind das 2
Millionen Menschen pro Jahr in den
nächsten zehn Jahren kommen wir dann auf
20 Millionen Migranten und hätten unsere
Bevölkerung mal ganz flott von 82 auf
über 100 Millionen Menschen gesteigert
irgendwann
müssen selbst Sie doch mal merken dass
sie jetzt schon bestehende wohnungsboot
beim besten willen da nicht mehr zu
lösen ist meine Damen und Herren und
wenn Sie auf unsere afd-fraktion schon
nicht hören wollen dann schreiben Sie es
doch bitte gerade Sie meine Damen und
Herren die immer die großen Zwischenrufe
sie können ganz besonders zuhören
schreiben sich die Worte des Präsidenten
des Bundesverbandes Deutscher wohnungs-
und Immobilienunternehmen hinter die
Ohren ich zitiere mit der Erlaubnis der
Präsidentin bislang reagiert die
Bundesregierung viel zu zögerlich und
verharrt in ihrer realitätsfernen
wünscht dir was Politik statt
ideologischer Träumereien braucht
Deutschland jetzt mehr denn je eine
handfeste und auf der Realität
basierende Energie Bau und
Wohnungspolitik Zitat Ende viel besser
hätte ich auch nicht ausdrücken können
ich danke Ihnen für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
Fraktionsvorsitzender der afd-fraktion
war das auf jeden Fall Anja Liebert sie
sitzt für die Grünen Fraktion im
Ausschuss für Wohnstadt Entwicklung
Bauwesen und Kommunen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die Prioritäten
und Schwerpunkte im Etat des
Bauministeriums liegen 2023 deutlich bei
der Entlastung der Bürgerinnen und
Bürger durch die Ausweitung des
Wohngeldes den zweiten
Heizkostenzuschuss und die
Wohnraumförderung
die Wohnungsfrage ist die soziale Frage
unserer Zeit wir schaffen Entlastungen
und Unterstützung für die Menschen die
aktuell am dringendsten darauf
angewiesen sind und die ampelregierung
handelt in großer sozialpolitischer
Verantwortung damit
und wir behalten gemeinsam mit den
sozialen Aspekten die langfristigen
Ziele der ökologischen Transformation
fest im Blick und deshalb haben wir die
Mittel für die nachhaltige
Stadtentwicklung deutlich verstetigt und
wir haben auch die passenden Instrumente
dafür gefunden zum Beispiel auch aus dem
Energie-
es geht darum dass wir mehr grün und
mehr Parks in den Städten schaffen
Frischluft Schneisen um besser mit der
Hitze umzugehen und auf der anderen
Seite brauchen wir
versickerungsflächen und schwamm statt
Konzepte um die Folgen von Starkregen
und Überflutungen abzumildern und laut
Ministerium ist genau dieses Programm
bereits fünffach überzeichnet die
Kommunen und viele haben ja vorhin
gesagt wie ist das denn mit den Kommunen
die Kommunen haben das Problem schnell
erkannt und wir müssen gerade die
Kommunen weiter unterstützen bei dem
Thema Klimaschutz und Klimaanpassung
ein weiteres Beispiel das
kfw-förderprogramm Maßnahmen zur
energetischen Stadtsanierung mit dem
Geld wird die Wärmeversorgung
öffentlicher Gebäude auf regional
verfügbare regenerative Energien
umgestellt oder industrielle
Prozesswärme in das Fernwärmenetz der
Kommunen eingespeist hier liegen so viel
Potenziale die wir heben müssen und die
wir mit Hilfe verschiedener
Bundesprogramme heben können aber auch
heben müssen und die Programme der
klassischen Städtebauförderung haben wir
mit den 790 Millionen Euro auf hohem
Niveau verstetigt es geht um
energetische Gebäudesanierung es geht
aber auch um flächen-
[Applaus]
und wir wollen die Städtebauförderung
als grüne zukünftig noch viel mehr als
Treiber auch für nachhaltige
Verkehrskonzepte und Stadtentwicklung
ausbauen für mehr Lebensqualität in den
Städten
mehr Geld für die Programme ist das eine
aber wir brauchen auch gemeinsam mehr
Mut denn wir müssen auch jenseits der
Haushaltsberatungen den Weg der
Transformation fortsetzen wir müssen
unsere Energieerzeugung unabhängig von
Gas und Kohle ausrichten Verfahren
vereinfachen Bürokratie abbauen und da
sind alle herzlich eingeladen
mitzumachen und auch dem Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren einen neuen Schub geben wir
machen das schon nächste Woche mit einer
kleinen baugesetzbuchnovelle und da
können sie gerne alle sich an der
Debatte dann auch beteiligen und Sie
sehen dass sich die Ampel mit dem Blick
nach vorne der Verantwortung stellt und
viel für die soziale Gerechtigkeit und
die sozialökologische Transformation
leistet vielen Dank
ja ab und zu gibt es auch eine
Punktlandung zeitlich
nächster Redner ist Timo schizanowski
für die SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der bis
heute unvergessenen Mutter Courage des
Ostens Regine Hildebrand stammt der Satz
das freudigste in der Politik ist es
Menschen helfen zu können Gesetze
hinzukriegen die diesen Zweck erfüllen
und deshalb haben wir heute allen Grund
zur Freude der mit dem vorliegenden Etat
für das Bauen und Wohnen haben wir ein
Haushaltsgesetz hingekriegt dass
Millionen Menschen in unserem Lande
hilft spürbar
spürbar und ganz vielfältig hilft
Millionen Menschen hilft die wir mit dem
Wohngeld unterstützen Millionen Menschen
hilft die vor Ort in den Kommunen von
einer verlässlichen Städtebauförderung
profitieren Millionen Menschen hilft die
im sozialen Wohnungsbau leben insgesamt
ermöglicht der Etat im kommenden Jahr
Gesamtausgaben von 7,3 Milliarden Euro
davon alleine für Zukunftsinvestitionen
in das Bauen und Wohnen knapp vier
Milliarden damit realisieren wir mehr
Gutes bezahlbares Wohnen und sorgen so
auch für soziale Sicherheit in unserem
Land und das allen gegenwärtigen Krisen
zum Trotz die wir anpacken um gezielt zu
helfen und genau deshalb haben wir erst
die jüngst hier das Wohngeld Plus auf
den Weg gebracht und hier fährt
zusätzliche 2,2 Milliarden Euro
bereitgestellt die mit Abstand größte
Änderung im vorliegenden Etat und mehr
Wohngeld für mehr Menschen das ist
richtig und wichtig damit dieser
historisch größten Reform haben wir das
Wohngeld endlich auf die Höhe der Zeit
gebracht eine Zeit
eine Zeit in der sich immer mehr
Menschen immer mehr Sorgen machen müssen
ganz besonders darüber ob sie angesichts
der steigenden Energiepreise ja hohen
Nebenkosten noch zahlen können vor allem
diejenigen Menschen die ohnehin schon
mit sehr wenig Geld auskommen müssen und
genau deshalb ist es uns als
SPD-Fraktion so wichtig mit dem
wohngeldplus exakt diejenigen zu
erreichen die es an dringendsten
brauchen Geringverdiener darunter viel
Alleinerziehende Menschen Rentnerinnen
und Rentner die fast die Hälfte der
Wohngeld beziehenden Haushalte ausmachen
sowie Familien mit geringen Einkommen
und ich erinnere mich noch sehr gut
daran SPD an den Info-Ständen zur
Bundestagswahl von den Menschen immer
wieder angesprochen worden sind auf das
Thema bezahlbares Wohnen und besonders
in Erinnerung geblieben ist ein Gespräch
nämlich das mit einem Familienvater aus
meiner Heimatstadt Hagen er war
Geringverdiener zwei kleine Kinder sechs
Tage Woche Pendler und doch trotz seiner
harten fleißigen Arbeit reicht es schon
damals kaum zum Leben und der er Vater
hat mir sichtlich bewegt erzählt wie
sehr ihn diese Situation und seine junge
Familie belastet ihr ständiges Gefühl
finanziell nicht mithalten zu können und
dass dieser Familie jetzt ab dem 1
Januar mit dem Wohngeld plus spürbar
geholfen wird dass es sozial und das ist
gerecht
denn der Vater
denn der Vater der sich jeden Morgen für
seine kleine Familie fleißig auf den Weg
zur Arbeit macht er verdient sich
tagtäglich unseren Respekt und unsere
Unterstützung dieser Vater und dieser
junge Familie sie stehen stellvertretend
für ganz viele Menschen in unserem Land
und genau ihn am Olaf Scholz und sie als
SPD vor einem Jahr mehr soziale Politik
versprochen gerade auch für das Bauen
und Wohnen und der vorliegende Etat er
ist ein weiterer ganz wichtiger Baustein
mit dem wir unser Versprechen halten
heute ist deshalb ein guter Tag für mehr
bezahlbares Wohnen und vor allem für
Millionen Menschen in unserem Land oder
um es im Sinne von Regine Hildebrand zu
sagen wir helfen Menschen da war das
richtig ordentliches hingekriegt
herzlichen Dank
Timo shisanowski war das für die
SPD-Fraktion und damit kommen wir zum
vorletzten Redner in der Debatte zum
Einzelplan sieht zum Einzelplan 25
danach kommt nämlich Einzelplan 17 jetzt
aber erst einmal Daniel Förster Sprecher
für Bau und Wohnungspolitik der
FDP-Fraktion sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin werte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
ich schließe mich ganz explizit der
kolleginette Teil von der Union an es
ist sehr gut dass es dieses
baumministerium gibt es ist ein
Ministerium das direkt 82 Millionen
Deutsche berührt weil wir alles regeln
was Menschen leben sie bauen sie wohnen
84 Millionen umso besser
Fachkräftemangel Liebe AFD wir brauchen
Zuwanderung dieses Ministerium berührt
84 Millionen Menschen und deswegen ist
es gut dass es gibt und auch gut das
klarer geil wird die Ministerin ist das
ist aber der einzige Punkt wo ich mich
der Union anschließen kann weil wirklich
ernsthaft werte Kolleginnen von cdu/csu
ich habe ja gar keine Lust darüber zu
reden wer wann was wo wie früher gemacht
hat und woran wir jetzt noch leiten ich
würde ja lieber mit euch darüber
diskutieren was sind die besten Lösungen
für die Zukunft aber leider müssen wir
ständig Sachen korrigieren die ihr uns
Unterschied die aus euren Häusern kommt
Kollege Hagen hat schon erwähnt die
Immobilienwert ermittlungsverordnung zu
Neuregelung der Erbschaftsteuer Erbe von
Horst Seehofer der also da könnt ihr
euch noch nicht hinstellen und sagen hey
was habt ihr denn da gemacht also macht
euch da mal ehrlich die Frau Ministerin
musste die falsche Aussage zum SJK
Programm korrigiert also bitte lass uns
doch nicht immer über die Vergangenheit
reden sondern über die Zukunft und
ständig müssen wir irgendwas korrigieren
was sie entweder falsch darstellt oder
uns Unterschieden wollt und was ist denn
das überhaupt für ein Bild jetzt wo ihr
keinen Bundeskanzler stellt seine
plötzlich gegen den Aufbau des
Bundeskanzleramt vor vielen Jahren war
die noch voll dafür also es soll euch
das denn bitte abnehmen
der Haushalt hat sehr viele gute Ansätze
er ist noch nicht perfekt es ist erst
das zweite Jahr in dass wir jetzt gehen
er hat gute Ansätze was uns sehr wichtig
ist als Freie Demokraten ist natürlich
die Eigentumsförderung sind
wir dahin wollen
[Musik]
in Eigentum bringen Eigentum schützt vor
Altersarmut
[Musik]
Eigentum so wichtig und wir sind dafür
den ersten Schritt gegangen wir sind
dafür den ersten Schritt gegangen wir
werden wir werden die Grunderwerbsteuer
reformieren wir werden Freibeträge
möglich machen gegen finanzieren über
die Schere dient was ich noch sehr gut
finde ist tatsächlich ein
bürgschaftsprogramm für da wo es noch am
Eigenkapital für das eine der größten
Hürden auf dem Weg ins Eigentum so und
das werden wir früher oder später alles
alles auf den Weg bringen und es wird
keine 10 Milliarden kosten
es wird keine zehn Milliarden kosten wie
das Baukindergeld 10 Milliarden Euro ich
gönne wirklich jedem der geschenktes
Geld vom Staat Minden ich könnte es
jedem aber 10 Milliarden Euro zu
investieren und am Ende eines sinkende
Eigentumsquote in Deutschland zu haben
das ist schon eine beeindruckende Fehler
eine beeindruckende Fehlleistung Geld
ist
das einrahmen ist das
andere
jetzt müssen wir den Regelungsrahmen so
umbauen dass wir mehr schneller und
günstiger bauen können in Deutschland
weil wir günstiger bauen kann auch
günstiger wohnen vielen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege für
letzte Rednerin 25 Sekunden
[Applaus]
herr Präsident liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen als ich 2009 mein Studium in
Frankfurt begonnen habe habe ich
versucht eine Wohnung zu finden direkt
in der Nähe von der Universität musste
dann aber feststellen das kann ich mir
nicht leisten ich hätte so weit in
Vorort von Frankfurt ziehen müssen dass
die Pendelei mindestens genauso lange
gedauert hätte wie wenn ich einfach bei
mir zu Hause in der Nähe von Mainz
wohnen bleibe und genau das muss ich
dann am Ende auch machen was anderes war
für mich finanziell zu Beginn meine
Studiums leider nicht drin
seitdem haben die Wohnungspreise noch
mal stark angezogen während ich das
Problem damals gut lösen konnte geht es
vielen jungen Menschen heute anders ich
frag mich wie viele müssen denn ihre
Pläne eigentlich ändern und wie viele
verzichten auf Ihren Wunsch Studienplatz
oder ihre Wunsch Ausbildung weil sie
sich eine Wohnung dazu einfach nicht
leisten können wie viele müssen ihre
berufliche Zukunft von der angespannten
Lage auf dem Wohnungsmarkt abhängig
machen es ist nur so demokratisches
Anliegen Aufstiegschancen zu ermöglichen
und Bildungsgerechtigkeit zu schaffen
und das bedeutet für mich auch junge
Menschen Auszubildenden und Studierenden
bezahlbaren Wohnraum zur Verfügung zu
stellen
denn alle jungen Menschen und nicht nur
die die von zu Hause aus mit mehr Geld
ausgestattet sind sollen die
Ausbildungs- und Studienplätze annehmen
können die ihren beruflichen Wünschen
entsprechen und nicht dem Wohnungsmarkt
daher freue ich mich als
Berichterstatterin für junges wohnen
sehr dass wir als Ampelkoalition 500
Millionen Euro in ein
bund-länderprogramm für studentisches
Wohnen junges Wohnen und Wohnen für
Auszubildende investieren als
Teilprogramm innerhalb des klassischen
sozialen Wohnungsbau es ist die zitiert
für junges Wohnen vorgesehen und es
erkennt den dringenden Bedarf in diesem
Bereich an wir unterstützen damit junge
Menschen in einer entscheidenden Phase
ihres Lebens die aufgrund ihrer
Einkommenssituation besonders auf
bezahlbaren Wohnraum angewiesen sind von
dem großen Bedarf an dieser Förderung
konnte ich mich vor kurzem bei einem
Besuch des studierendenwerkes Frankfurt
am Main überzeugen betreibt nämlich zwei
Wohnheime in meinem Wahlkreis in
Rüsselsheim und wie in so vielen
Bereichen stellen die steigenden
Nebenkosten die explodierenden Preise im
Bausektor und der Mangel an bebaubaren
Flächen die studierendenwerke für große
Herausforderungen hinzukommt in meinem
Heimatland in Hessen das ist ihnen
gesetzlich erschwert wird auch an
Menschen in Ausbildung zu vermieten
dabei ist es bezahlbarer Wohnraum dabei
ist bezahlbarer Wohnraum für
Auszubildende genauso knapp hier muss
ich dringend etwas ändern
studierendenwerke verfolgen im Gegensatz
zu Investoren keine Rendite und
Gewinnabsichten aufgrund ihres
sozialauftrags zielen sie auf
preisgünstige mieten und vergeben
Wohnraum nach dem sozialen Bedarf nicht
nach der Zahlungsfähigkeit der
MieterInnen bundesweit wohnen derzeit
jedoch nur knapp zehn Prozent der
Studierenden in Wohnheim das ist klar
ausbaufähig und dringend notwendig wenn
sich jeder junge Mensch im Studium
leisten können sollen mit dem neuen Bund
länderprogramm stellen wir als
Ampelkoalition den Ländern eine große
Summe zur Verfügung mit dem klaren Ziel
bezahlbaren Wohnraum für junge Menschen
zu schaffen und damit sind Studierende
und Auszubildende gleichermaßen gemeint
wir füllen damit einen zentralen
wohnungspolitischen Auftrag aus dem
Koalitionsvertrag und unterstreichen
dass wir den drängenden Bedarf in diesem
Segment erkannt haben und nun wünsche
ich mir dass diese Mittel zahlreich
abgerufen werden wenn kein Studium und
keine Ausbildung zahlt ein mangelnden
Wohnraum scheitern vielen Dank
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin damit schließe
ich die Aussprache
ein Plan
für uns Ministerium von Bundesministerin
Klara Gallwitz
7,33 Milliarden Euro bekommen sollte im
Jahr und bevor wir aber zum nächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt kommen gibt es hier
noch ein Änderungsantrag der
Unionsfraktion
20 Bundesministerium für Wohnungen wurde
aber eben schon abgelehnt in diesem Art
die Union unter anderem mehr Geld für
die Förderung städtebaulicher Maßnahmen
gefordert aber wie gesagt das wurde hier
abgelehnt